so the new trailer for x-men apocalypse
is out and I don't like it and at first
I didn't know why I didn't like it I
just washed it and was like I was
completely underwhelmed by that and I
knew I would have to watch it a few more
times to figure out why that was but I
really didn't want to just nothing about
that thing landed for me I have figured
out why so I can quantify this all not
just bitching the first is there's
really nothing that this trailer shows
us that is different from the first Rose
not even a different field that doesn't
give us any more story information than
the last trailer gave us and it's just
hitting the same beats in many cases
reusing the same footage I mean we see a
little bit more of some stuff we see a
little bit more of mystique as mystique
instead of as Jennifer Lawrence we see a
bit more of apocalypse but I mean it
just feels like extensions of the stuff
that was in the last trailer none of it
feels new so it feels redundant first of
all so that's the first thing but the
bigger thing is i'm getting a spider-man
3 vibe off this thing guys and what I
mean by that if you're either too young
to remember or have just chosen to
forget if you watched the marketing the
trailers and the interviews from the
cast when spider-man 3 was coming out
everybody just had this feeling of yep
we did another one we sure did it just
had this feel of contractual obligation
like nobody was really psyched to be in
it and I'm getting that vibe off almost
everybody in this trailer it really
first started hitting me with the line
that we hear I don't know who says it I
think it might be more she has this line
where we hear he's basically like a god
and he's going to rise again and she
says it with this tone that I
practically expected her to end that
sense with but whatever and that's just
the vibe I'm getting from almost
everybody nobody seems excited to be
here even Quicksilver his line well you
wanted me to get out of the house every
was just this disaffected thing and I
really really hope it's just putting
together a bad trailer where they just
picked moments where the characters have
a reason to feel disaffected and they've
just for some stupid reason stuck all
that in the trailer and it lent to this
vibe I read
we hope that's not the vibe of the
overall movie but it is the vibe I yet
from this trailer I also don't like the
whole digitize neo modulation that
they've added to apocalypses voice I
know I might have been the only person
but i really liked when we saw the first
trailer that we just heard Oscar Isaacs
voice and it wasn't modulated and it
wasn't messed with to me that spoke to
just trust in him as an actor in like
he's gonna bring this we don't need to
mess with his voice let him do his thing
and I guess enough people bitched in
multi doesn't sound apocalyptic enough
and now they're much ladies like I don't
like it nearly as much but coming back
to people don't want to be here I don't
think Jennifer Lawrence could look any
more bored whether she is mystique or
whether she is looking more human she
just looks bored as heck to be here and
again maybe when we get to the film
it'll all make sense in these snippets
of the chose put into the context of
scenes will all work and it'll be great
but the fact that they could not put
together true that told me anything more
than the first one did and it now has
lent this vibe guys this has gone from
one of my most anticipated movies of
this year to one that I'm really now
heavily nervous about I also don't think
the effects look very good everything
just looks really really fake the green
screen looks incredibly green screening
the shot of Quicksilver the shot of
Cylon and I mean psylocke looks tough
and badass and Olivia Munn has this look
on her face like okay she's putting an
effort fine but you know you look at the
scene overall in the effect of the car
it's like okay that's cool but it looks
really fake apocalypse growing huge it
looks really fake I mean I'm God guys
this looks like Jack the giant slayer
fox lay off the marketing cuz I was
excited for this movie on the basis of
the first trailer because that was scant
enough that I wasn't going to project
too much hope on it now you give me a
second trailer that has offered me
nothing more I've started to pick apart
what you're showing me and this is not
in your favor no more stuff if you're
gonna do another trailer it better give
me some more serious deep moments the
only thing that I liked about this
trailer was the way that it opened that
call back to that line from the first
movie that bit of dialogue between
Magneto and Professor X that was great
but it was all downhill after that if
you're gonna do any more trailers give
me more of that and I can get excited
for this again because right now I'm
just not so the new x-men apocalypse
trailer I'm assuming you've seen it what
were your
it's on it am I completely off base or
do you think I'm talking some sense
whatever you think is going on drop
something down in the comments and let's
talk about it please remember to Like
subscribe check me out on Twitter at
Council of geeks find the Council of
geeks podcast on iTunes and stitcher and
until next time this council is
adjourned